be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about the Red Lantern Corps
and what I'm hoping is that at the end
of this video you'll have a solid
understanding of why the group came into
existence and more importantly why fans
love them so much
in 1994 with the removal of Hal Jordan
as the Green Lantern and his replacement
at the hands of Kyle Rayner DC had found
the fan reaction among Hal Jordan fans
following this decision was one of
intense negativity while Kyle Rayner
would go on to introduce a new
generation of readers to the Green
Lantern mythos many previous readers
felt betrayed and seeing how Jordan
arguably the most iconic Green Lantern
depicted in a manner that caused him to
succumb to fear lose his sanity and
eventually died while DC made multiple
attempts to correct this depiction of
Hal Jordan and shine his death in a more
favorable light
DC's unwillingness to return him to the
position of the premier Green Lantern in
their continuity maintained this line of
demarcation regarding hardcore Hal
Jordan fans and their willingness to buy
into this new line of titles as a result
with sales in a decline following Kyle
Rayner introduction in 2004 Geoff Johns
was brought on board in an effort to
launch a campaign that would see how
Jordan restored to the DC landscape as
the premier Green Lantern and to this
end Geoff Johns began taking steps to
expand the Green Lantern mythos over the
course of a series of stories that would
become known as a Geoff Johns Green
Lantern epic in a 2013 interview with
Kelly Book Resources following the
conclusion of his run on the Green
Lantern series Geoff Johns had stated
that his inspiration for launching this
new series of stories had its roots in
his personal experiences and personal
losses as well as the events surrounding
September 11 2001 with much of the
United States Krypton fear following
this event as well as the personal
ramifications for him the Geoff Johns
took to using the Green Lantern series
as an outlet for his feelings and
perceptions of the power of emotion and
self analysis beginning with the
introduction of the blackest night
prophecy and it's telling of a war
between all lanterns of the emotional
spectrum Geoff Johns took the next step
of establishing that with the Green
Lantern's powered by willpower and with
the Sinestro Corps powered by fear these
groups existed as only part of the
emotional spectrum alongside these two
previously established teams exist
new groups of lantern cores consisting
of the blue lanterns powered by hope the
orange lantern powered by avarice or
greed the indigo lanterns powered by
compassion the previously existing star
sapphires powered by love the white
lanterns powered by life the black
lanterns powered by death and finally
the red lanterns powered by rage
so while the origins of the Red Lanterns
were initially provided over the course
of geoff johns original run because the
Red Lanterns had received their own solo
series with the new 52 and because their
origin doesn't change from the original
what we're going to do is reference Red
Lanterns issue number zero as well as
several other sources in order to
establish this complete backstory over
the course of the pre new 52 and the new
52 continuities what we're told here is
that the history of the Red Lantern
Corps predates the Green Lantern Corps
itself and that when the guardians of
the universe had launched their campaign
to provide a police force for the cosmos
their first attempt came in the form of
the robotic Manhunters designed for the
purpose now served by the Green
Lantern's a programming glitch occurred
causing the Manhunters to believe that
in order for peace to exist in the
universe it would have to be devoid of
all life beginning a conquest of various
planets their efforts eventually led
them to Sector 666 attacking the planets
in killing virtually all occupants the
Manhunters left failing to realize if
five individuals had survived the
massacre one of which was a being named
Atrocitus a fuel by the rage over the
loss of their races their friends and
their families combined with the belief
that the guardians of the universe are
responsible but lacking leadership the
group elected Atrocitus to oversee their
operations undertaking the name of the
five inversions the group spent
centuries waging war against the
guardians of the universe destroying
countless man hunters in their quest the
group establishes what's called the
Empire of Tears an affiliation of worlds
powered by their rage and hatred of the
guardians eventually manipulating and
becoming romantically involved with one
of the other five inversions Atrocitus
learns the power of the blood prophecy
the ability to kill others and use their
blood in a manner that allows for
glances into the future capturing one of
the Guardians and killing him Atrocitus
puts this magic to use by peering into
the future and seeing the other members
of the five inversions dead with himself
atop an ocean of blood realizing that
the prophecy is telling him of his
ascension to power
Atrocitus kills the five inversions
collecting their power unto himself by
way of a blood magic ritual he forms a
red power battery the source power for
the Red Lantern Corps
with this newfound power Atrocitus ins
rings throughout the universe much like
the other power ranks the Red Lantern
ring select those best suited to wield
them but due to the basis behind the
creation the red power ring seek out
those whose hearts are filled with rage
as is described to us when an individual
accepts and falls under the power of a
Red Lantern ring virtually all semblance
of their former selves are erased driven
by their rage on a mind consuming level
most wielders of the Red Lantern rings
are virtually mindless casting aside all
sense of morality and decency to defeat
their various foes
so following the introduction of the Red
Lantern Corps our fans immediately
latched onto the idea where the history
of the red lantern continuity has
largely consisted of battles between the
Green Lantern Corps and Sinestro yellow
Lantern Corps with occasional
appearances by the star sapphires fans
welcomed the idea of a more expansive
continuity involving a multitude of new
Lantern cores in addition to this the
existence of the red lanterns as a
result of past failures regarding the
guardians of the universe provided a
richer continuity previously the
failures of the Guardians largely
involved their casting out of Hal Jordan
or else the byproduct of their strict
standards of universal perception with
the red lanterns however this
capitalized on the idea that the
failures of the Guardians had
far-reaching consequences affecting not
just themselves but the universe as a
whole
a furthermore the Red Lantern Corps
driven by rage and being introduced as
the antithesis to the Green Lantern's
willpower provided readers with battles
of discipline versus mindlessness and
with the red lanterns consisting of
beings not constrained by concepts like
morality these battles took a break away
from the tradition of foes pummeling one
another with hard light constructs and
instead often introduced bloody fights
with former members of the green or
Sinestro Lantern Corps falling from
grace so to speak and joining the Red
Lanterns themselves with that being said
we're gonna go ahead and ring this video
to an end I hope you guys enjoyed it and
I will catch you guys later peace